[Music]
all right in accidental trip news o
submitted by the one and only you guys
know yeah yeah a man restoring a classic
synthesizer accidentally goes on a
nine-hour acid trip who what how do you
accidentally do that from a synthesizer
maybe there was acid that was hidden on
the on the keys who said the sizer was
in so this was owned by Cal State
University which one they just say Cal
State University but which [ __ ] antenna
mom I think they don't want to say la
Long Beach boulders feel synthesizing
what the music department
it's alright they're just saying that I
just read Cal State University baby
journalism is what happened
oh yeah cuz I don't they got hush money
from the skew they do mention San
Francisco somebody's up there okay
tomorrow now okay so they're saying that
this person was a broadcast operations
manager at this station in San Francisco
volunteered to fix and restore this
synthesizer and so it was the school's
music department they had originally
purchased this instrument back in the
60s to help this school stay on top of
the changes in the music industry but
then over time the synthesizer broke
down and then it was just stored away in
a corner of a classroom and so that's
when this guy came around he started
disassembling the synthesizer and it
seemed to look like so he noticed a
crystal like residue stuck under one of
the instruments knobs and so it tasted
it
yeah he blasted it with the cleaning
solvent and then he rubbed it off with
his finger and in 45 minutes later he
started to experience a tingling
sensation that's acid and so then he
took three three separate chemical tests
later that classic acid they identified
that the substance was LSD so which can
be heard through the skin was like an
activator like an alcohol - and open up
the portal yeah maybe that but yeah
they're saying that it can survive for
decades gates I I know this kid that had
a liquid vial and it cracked in his
pocket and in the liquid and he was
tripping balls for many many hours yeah
yeah I had no idea could go through your
skin like that I didn't know you people
put that [ __ ] in their eyeball and [ __ ]
oh really mm-hmm that like barbed but
that sounds like a bar LSD contacts
that's crazy girl
I heard LSD context I heard that like
you put on your contacts how do you
write to go with an acid no never
oh I would I thought all dancers were
the drug types I just think like well I
didn't know there were so many more
difficult less convenient ways to take
it then just look especially white
people they just get they always try to
put something up there but you know
going crazy so I used to go to this
school full of white people you would
take the whites love acid yeah we would
take ecstasy right I always try to put
some kind of drug in there a pill form
already so it's easy it's like a
Flintstones it's easy if you were to
orally and chest it they even have to
crush it and snort it or stick it up
their ass
what no one doesn't the way the doctor
recommended yeah
Oh for like max potency or something
yeah they're [ __ ] crazy only why do
you have like let me put it in my let me
put my air they try to find all kind of
seems like like a really elaborate lie
like he's like he did at got caught on
acid and he's like actually and it just
like built up to like okay so you tell
me there was a synthesizer you're trying
to clean it and like visible
them gaining high when you're not
expecting to get high is kind of scary
that is because you're not like you you
didn't sign up for it but it's oops
oh that's it happened to me what you got
drunk yeah remember I told you guys so I
was at a rave with my sister and she
gave me a bottle of water and there was
no sir
so it was like a pill that you take
apart like a vitamin and she called this
tree crystal but I think it was that
crystal white no better bitter it was
very bitter but I didn't realize it
until after those [ __ ] thirsty I was
dancing that's pure yeah I could go to
Mali or something I can get one and then
she tells me she's like hey you're
feeling good and then it's like I heard
eating like crazy I started at the same
time she's so [ __ ] fun roofied by
your own sister starts laughing cuz she
was already [ __ ] up and I was just
like hell yeah wait why what and then
she was like did you swallow the the
casing at the end of the bottom of the
bottle and I was like what in Hey look
and you could see the the casing of the
pill
I started [ __ ] tripping out like I
was having a bad trip at that point cuz
I was so scared I'm like somebody that
we know - that you would never expect to
do crazy well actually you might but he
was at he was at a club I'll tell you
guys after but he was at a club and he
was dancing with the girl and she asked
him if you wanted to take a bullet he
didn't know what the flesh it was and so
she literally had him snorted and he
didn't know what was going on what the
[ __ ] huh [ __ ] dumb when she was like
she was making out with them he was like
what's that and she kind of just like
should just believe in anything and he
[ __ ] inhaled it tripping balls in the
bathroom life going on over to die cuz
he didn't know what we know this person
you don't wait I would love to play drug
roulette like if you're like one of
these days
during this month or maybe four of them
I'm a [ __ ] during this mob like when
you're at a dark Club though and a hot
girl comes up to your starts making out
with you it says anything yeah but you
said a dark Club she's probably busted
his [ __ ] of late club dark I'm afraid
she might have a that's why she had to
drug it you think maybe you could judge
me anytime I'll get mad
no but then after that I've dressed I'm
having a really bad trip okay my sister
started calming me down she's like hey
listen it's already too late you might
as well enjoy it and then she started
turning into a [ __ ] octopus enjoy did
you get a massage no did you get a light
show no she doesn't know how to give you
a good trip no we're pretty we're
camping at that rave too so dang I know
what era this was this is like even a TV
was like playing whole album was made by
pitch bends oh dude no we listen the
psychedelic trip even lower in the
ground you guys you guys do i Aloha
I want to I've never done it I'm kind of
scared I'm scared of the puking positive
that you have to puke when you take a
lot of people puke and it's like
acceptable that you throw up
really yeah I've ever seen any I just
want them it's like kind of like
motorcycles right to me right so like a
majority people I know that consistently
ride motorcycles have been in a major
[ __ ] accident right and half the
people that I know that did ayahuasca
some people had a great experience but
the people had a bad experience it was
but the people they had bad experience
are they usually positive people yes
oh yeah so it's I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is I've never had a bad trip my
whole life well I heard that ayahuasca
it is one of those things that you just
cannot control itself oh yeah and then
you might have an 8-hour nightmare but
some people come out of those our night
to say they come out of it and if we
want to talk about their inner demons
yeah
a lot of people do that too it's like
going through Dante's Inferno his active
ingredient is covet but isn't isn't one
like two hours versus four days like
saying THC yes of marijuana it's the
active ingredient it's DMT but but
ayahuasca is the drink that that makes
you trip for a long time there's a
smokeable form I wanna do that that's
like a 10-minute trip okay I wanted to
that one nobody got a lick of toads out
you you know but you don't go through
like you don't go through like a long
journey with yourself it's okay I like
short journeys first and I'll test it
out I'd be like I was cool I take that
and it rewires me and I'm just like in
the normal world
well the JK news will fail dude so
anything you do never take that fine
yeah we're talking about this guy who
accidentally went on a nine-hour trip oh
you know dancers all I feel like they
all do drugs like a lot of drugs what's
in shrooms except me could you attest to
this bro I didn't do dude I don't even
put Neosporin on cuts I don't do nothing
the seventh day runs deep in here yeah
that's crazy that's my habit just not
doing your will have you put LSD Annika
never that's that's the way I take it
drug in your life never take a simple
drug never drink alcohol what do you
[ __ ] better than I am no it's just
we've come I never did a hard drug
besides a lot of alcohol
oh that's already harsh man I don't know
about everything them well know they're
talking I'm just laughing if you notice
all right all right
Dietrich's doesn't do anything any
number drinks to now yeah like most of
the quest they're like the dancers that
don't do that's so [ __ ] I mean you
guys are a tutoring business your name
your name that I swear it it's it's like
it's just coincidence there's no like we
don't have like an active thing against
it like my whole life like I love the
environment of people high or drunk but
it's just I hate them you do like when
I'm in a situation and everybody else is
drunk except for me I [ __ ] it
hate them but when I drink me to fight
that I'm cool with anything it's just
entertaining to me like you're looking
at a drug-free coupe right here it
doesn't seem like you're right now cuz
I'm just talking like half like just
talking to Joe mama over there that's
the [ __ ] member jomama goodness but
this group right here they're surprised
because we don't do any of that
I'll do anything we smoke weed though
I'm trying to be a mom you ever smoke
weed in a meadow but I had ankle pains
the other day and I needed to smoke some
weed
hatsue
[Music]